>>Tucker: A NEW ROYAL BABY IS
COMING.
THEY PLAN TO RAISE THEIR BABY IN
A "GENDER FLUID" WAY.
IT'S A DECISION THAT MORE AND
MORE PARENTS ARE MAKING THESE
DAYS.
TO EXPLAIN THE TREND, WE HAVE
CATHY, OUR LIBERAL SHERPA,
JOINING US TONIGHT.
THE CORE IDEA AS I UNDERSTAND IT
IS THAT SEX, MALE AND FEMALE
DECEMBER DESIGNATIONS, ARE
CREATIONS OF SOCIETY.
AND SO, YOU CAN KIND OF CHOOSE
WHETHER YOUR CHILD IS A BOY OR A
GIRL.
IS THAT THE IDEA?
>> THE CHILD WILL CHOOSE WHAT
THE CHILD WANTS TO DO.
WE ARE FACING A GENDERLESS
FUTURE, GENDER-NEUTRAL FUTURE.
MAINSTREAM MAGAZINES ARE COMING
WITH UNISEX NAMES FOR CHILDREN,
SO THEY CAN FIT INTO THIS FUTURE
OF A GENDERLESS SOCIETY.
>> LEAVING ASIDE THE SCIENTIFIC
QUESTION OF WHETHER THIS IS
FANTASY.
>> IT IS REALITY.
>> LET ME ASK YOU WHY YOU WOULD
WANT A GENDERLESS SOCIETY.
ISN'T IT THE WHOLE POINT THAT
THE SEXES ARE DIFFERENT AND
THAT'S A GOOD THING?
WHY WOULD YOU WANT TO ELIMINATE
THOSE DIFFERENCES?
>> WE'RE ALWAYS TEACHING OUR
CHILDREN TO BE WHO THEY WANT TO
BE.
WILL SMITH SAYS HIS SON IS
FEARLESS.
JADEN SMITH IS NOT AFRAID TO
WEAR SKIRTS OR DRESSES.
>> WE'RE NOT ENCOURAGING THEM TO
BE UNIQUE.
YOU JUST SAID WE'RE ENCOURAGING
THEM TO BE ALL THE SAME, UNISEX.
EVERYONE'S THE SAME, SEXLESS
DRONE.
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> OKAY.
IT'S IN IGNORING DIFFERENCES,
WE'RE ACCENTUATING DIFFERENCES?
>> IF THE BOY WANTS TO WEAR A
DRESS, THAT'S OKAY.
THE GIRL DOESN'T WANT TO WEAR A
DRESS AND PLAY WITH BARBIES,
THAT'S OKAY.
>> I'M NOT ARGUING WITH THAT.
BUT I'M CONFUSED ABOUT THE
DETAILS.